Stewart is with us in South Carolina hi
Stuart
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
daddy thanks for having me
sure what's up I've got a quick question
actually a two-part question and I think
I know what you're going to say but I
just I wanted to hear it out of out of
your mouth
my wife would kind of rather hear from
you than me too yeah so it back in 2018
we took out a stupidly we took out a
401k loan out of her 401k and in
November of 2018 we found out she was
pregnant with our third child and so now
let's go to July she had my daughter and
has now stay-at-home mom and we
basically leaving the 401k loan with
about $11,000 balance and so I was doing
our taxes last night and we never did
get it at 1089 our you know showing that
that amount and I called the retirement
company and they said that basically we
have until March 31st to pay that off
before it shows us debt on this year you
know I guess on 2020s yeah before he's
considered an early withdrawal which
point you will be taxed and penalized
right so I'm not but my question for you
is is without with her leaving her job
which was about 65,000 a year basically
going down to nothing for 2020 would you
recommend and I'll say this too I can
come up with the funds and without going
into debt to pay this off that's where
it was pretty much that's which it would
pretty much wipe us out that's what you
should do okay and then
so my second question is if she'll have
about I guess 60,000 in that 401 K then
well then roll that to an IRA and engage
smart investor Pro into a rollover and
spread it across four types of mutual
funds growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international a
401 L a loan falls in baby step two and
if you have no other debt it's the last
remaining debt and baby step two and
when you're in baby step to getting out
of debt we teach folks to stop investing
and to pay off all of their debts except
their home listing them smallest to
largest and take any money that they
have access to to pay those debts and
that's all I'm doing here right so so
basically you know why everything out
then
then there's no dead so you can build it
back up baby step 1 is $1,000 in the
savings - as debt-free everything but
the house including paying off 401k
loans no money in any investment or
savings account then unless it's a
retirement account until you have your
debt paid off and so any money you have
which apparently you've got some
squirreled away we're going to use that
to clear this debt do you have any other
debt other than your home well I
actually just sold a $65,000 fix that's
right last week and so I had to I had to
take out a personal loan to cover that
distance but okay and how much is now
that 10,000 okay and you got 11,000 on
this what other loans do you have other
than your house that's it and how much
money do you have in savings so where
are you gonna get 11,000 to pay the 401k
loan oh there was a five thousand for
tax return for this year or for 2019
okay do you need to adjust your w-4 is
that's a huge tax return it is a little
more than I than I anticipated but don't
know the government $500 a month
interest free next year you did this
year
right a gesture w-4 to have the proper
amount withheld you don't need an
interest-free savings account with the
federal government that's what a refund
is dude okay so you got the five
thousand and the seven thousand is
twelve and you got eleven and you got
ten right right and your household
income is what this year will probably
be around ninety two hundred good okay
so if you follow what I teach which
works by the way we're going to take the
five thousand and the seven thousand
we're going to pay off the loan at the
401 K because if you don't do it by
March 31st you're gonna get hammered for
another five or six thousand dollars in
tax problems okay and so we're gonna
probably or that that leaves you only
with the amount of loan you have left
from the leftover from the truck and you
have one thousand dollars in your
account you're on a tight budget you
make 90 thousand dollars a year you're
gonna pay off ten thousand dollars in
three months maybe four months something
like that and then you're gonna build
your emergency fund back up of three to
six months of expenses which is too thin
right now anyway but we're going to
build it up from that thousand dollar up
to three to six months of expenses in
your house that's probably fifteen grand
and you're gonna have zero payments but
a house payment in fifteen grand in the
bank when you finish that those three
steps that's gonna feel pretty good with
the new baby yeah okay and that's
exactly following the baby steps of
exactly what we teach okay I'm gonna
give you a copy of the book the Total
Money Makeover which it outlines exactly
how the baby steps work on steroids
every little nuance in detail and it'll
show you two how to do what I just
outlined for you as well so hold on and
I'll have Kelley pick up and we'll get
you signed up for that thanks for the
call folks we've said it before but I'll
cover it again since he brought it up
never borrow on your 401k let me try
this again never
there's no caveat to this there's no
except but what about never
never here's why number one you unplug a
good investment you've got it in good
mutual funds making ten or twelve
percent and now you're paying yourself
interest which is really talking about a
dog chasing its tail right here and it's
only three it's only like five or six
percent interest then when you leave
your job and you will leave your job
when you die get a better job or go home
to be with a baby I don't know you're
gonna leave the job the loan is called
due which is what happened to him you
don't pay it on time it's called an
early withdrawal and the hits you with
taxes and penalties to the tune of forty
to fifty percent never borrow on your
401k